i'm talking to shaq uh two weeks ago you
know at the event
and shaq's at the mgm grand arena we're
having a conversation
and i said so tell me about your
upbringing your relationship values and
principles that your dad taught you
and he says my dad would tell me
if you listen to me i'll make you the
most dominant big man of all time
so your dad told you that he told me
that
okay what else and all these other
stories you hear about with shaq and his
dad you know his dad would say he
finished this
he was a drill sergeant so everything
was yes sir yes sir yes sir he had that
kind of a dad very much of a
disciplinarian right who raised them
what are some stories with your paps you
know you obviously a lot of it has been
heard but what are some stories about
your dad on how he raised you and
tristan
yeah my father was i believe the best
father on the planet i think that
every son should hopefully think the
same of their father i think a father's
role is to be a superhero
i think a father's role is to
i think one of the big mistakes in
modern society is that people think that
father should be a second mother and i
disagree i think a father should be a
superhero and sometimes a superhero
needs to go do superhero things my
father wasn't always home
he was away
but when he came home he came home with
a story
and i think that the quality of his
presence was more important than the
quantity of his presence
he raised us with absolute duty to our
last name he made it very very clear for
a very long time that being a tape means
something and that you have to live an
honorable life and a life that's true to
god because of that and also his
expectations to us were exceptionally
high because we were tates when i did
something fantastic when i became state
chess champion age of five or when i um
did exceptionally well my sats he moved
me up two grades et cetera i didn't come
home and say dad i did this and go wow
good job he was like well you're a tate
duh who are you competing against i was
like well the other kids at school who
are they don't know exactly
of course so we always had this huge
expectation of us and made it clear that
the last name means something
and we have to stay true to it
and and i think that this is kind of
something that's missing from modern
society when you have a duty to your
bloodline and a duty to your ancestors
that is something which
you carry with yourself
away from cameras and away from the eyes
of the outside world
so it's been something that's been
massively beneficial to me even when i
went through hard times in my life i
understood that being a tape prevented
me from doing anything that's
detrimental to myself
even basic things we talked about let's
say heartbreak if i had my heart broken
when i was young instead of chasing a
girl and embarrassing myself i could sit
in my room alone and think i'm a tape i
can't do that
i can't that's not how tates act
love you very much goodbye and i missed
her with all my heart but that that was
the game
let her go [ __ ] someone else and just be
heartbroken a while and get over it
because i felt a duty to my last name so
what he did exceptionally well was
instilled duty to the bloodline and duty
to the ancestors we understood who my
family were understood where we came
from knew who my grandfather was my
grandfather grandfather was etcetera and
he always had very very high
expectations of me
and it's it's often interesting people
say
you know if you have too high
expectations on kids it's bad for them
i can only talk from my personal
experience the fact that such high
expectations were held for me were a
massive benefit benefit to me
my father was a disciplinarian
he was also in the air force if i [ __ ]
up he hit me
he never beat me he never abused me but
there was certainly a realm in which i
if i [ __ ] up i get slapped only
happened two twice maybe ever but i knew
it was an option
twice in my life yeah because and i say
this i said this on i said this on
twitter
when i had a twitter account someone
saying that kids is bad and i said yeah
i understand you can't abuse kids it's
fine line i know it's a very nuanced
detailed argument
but
in the real world
there are lines that if you cross
violence appears
why get in your face as a man and start
running my mouth
sooner or later it becomes physical
that's the real world so
as an upbringing of a child i think
there should be lines that if they're
crossed violence appears i don't see
anything wrong with that i was never
abused in any way but if i really [ __ ]
up and both times now in hindsight i
[ __ ] up massive and i learned and i
was taught oh [ __ ] that's a line
and i think especially with young men if
there's never going to be a physical
line
what line is there
especially with young rebellious men i
don't know but maybe that shaped my
mindset for a long time because i always
understood there are lines that if you
cross things become physical and i've
always kept that in mind for how i
conduct myself i say this all the time
once again i said some youtube videos i
don't argue with people
if i get in a disagreement on the street
i don't argue i don't hey bro are you
parked
that's not who i am i'm like okay bro
leave it leave it i leave it to the last
second until i feel like there's no
other choice and then it's pure violence
i don't because i don't see the point in
arguing it's that's feminine to me a
verbal argument like i try my very best
to de-escalate because you never know
you're [ __ ] with and you never know
if they want to go to jail but
there's a line and it gets to that line
where there's that's the only possible
repercussion that's all that can happen
and i try very hard to stay away from
that line but i've always been very
aware that line is there and that served
me very very well in my life
the morgue and the prison
both of them are full of egos
and and because i know i can handle
myself i'm the number one guy to talk
down a fight but once i realize that
talking ain't gonna work i'm the
complete opposite and i think that that
was taught by my father that's how i was
taught if you enjoyed this video and you
want to watch the entire podcast click
over here and if you want to be
connected with experts influencers such
as
kiyosaki tate connolly palmentary myself
and others download the app minect where
you get a chance to connect with these
folks by the minute you get to buy the
minute or have face times with them 15
minutes ask him any questions you may
want to have download the admin act and
start connecting with influencers and
experts today
[Music]